je n'ai jamais douté quand votre bail
est celui qui est meilleur mais dimanche
établi une entrée en matière
humoristique
il faut dire que la barbe de olivier
bérisson fait parfois l'objet de
quelques commentaires
mais le président de moon n'a évidemment
pas rassembler ses partisans pont par
les pilosités mais plutôt de sa vision
pour la commune du saint-esprit nous
sommes dans une commune riche en eau en
cours d'eau en sauce donc il faut les
réhabiliter nous avons une commune
agricole de croissance et toutes les
terres nos cordes et koné refaire vivre
seulement chez lui donner ce dynamisme
et puis il ya une place des fêtes qu'il
peut qu'il faut aménager
il ya des salles de spectacles qu'il
faut réaménager intégré à fait que nos
artistes puissent se produire
il y à une fête patronale et
communiquent à manille c'est à dire avec
toutes les conversations et pas
seulement une seule parmi ses colistiers
différentes générations des artisans des
entrepreneurs des professionnels de
santé spiritains de que roux de
naissance séduit par les qualités
humaines qui prêta olivier bérisson on
va commencer par gagner mais il est
fendue et il se bat pour notre pays
essentiellement connu pour son
militantisme associatif
l'ancien président de l'as obama tente
une nouvelle entrée dans le monde
politique et pour la première fois pour
mandat de maire oui parce qu'à qui est
ce qui donne les subventions la grille
mais qui est ce qu'organise la société
c'est le politique qui prend la décision
au final donc nous nous battons pour que
les politiques qui sont un peu en
léthargie se réveille autant que ceux
qui sont réveillés prenez les rênes de
la soie politique
la dernière tentative remonte à 12 ans
c'était lors des élections municipales
et cantonales de 2008